who wins in a fight a lion or a bear
just for you right no not a pull well
yes it's a good question you're all
you're polar bear is pretty impressive
no Grizzly Bear Grizzly Bear
I think of Christy Bell wins well who
was the most threatening predator in
Australia
whoa okay it's a tricky question here
because
everyone's scared of the animals in
Australia but
I mean you have been blessed now you've
been by spider that's not that bad bear
America bill just hold you down to eat
you that's a much more terrifying
Prospect for me even shocks shock's
gonna be quick no one sees a shotgun the
shock's just gonna watch it maybe we'll
take a bite and chew a bear just holds
you down and eats you so that's uh
that's frightening for me Australia is a
bunch of just weird [__] that could kill
you
juicy cocaine Bear the movie that's
coming out I saw the trailer it looks
good yeah yeah so there's not every bear
there's like black bolts in this black
balls there's bears and there's Bears so
that I think that's what they often
don't talk about everybody puts lions
and bears in the same category I think
there's just some weak Bears a lion
would kill a black bear I think not
everybody again I'm trying to tell you
there's there's a difference but Grizzly
and polarbound betting on those yeah no
I think Grizzlies have the size but
actually every video I've seen of
Grizzlies they tie out within like 20
seconds they get bored that's the gas
tank yeah this guy that's a Nikki Ryan
guest thing right yeah that's all that's
all I got dream old and they try to just
uh they try to just take a breather like
there's these crazy fights between bears
in the last like 20 seconds I heard this
story about a a Russian family that was
attacked by a bear in Russia and uh
killed the dad and it took so it took so
long to eat the daughter she made three
phone calls to her mom while I was
eating her and the first cook the one
thought she was pranking her
that's crazy that's way scarier though
give me a snake bite food yeah you know
what let me let me change the question
is
um like if you had to
uh fight a bear or a lion
how would you try to defeat it do you
think you have a chance at all well I
think I'd uh I'd attack a line a little
bit differently
we'll give the difference okay well I've
seen this video where
um a lions are eating and and you have
three like scritty guys walk up behind
them and kind of scare the cat off of
off their food I think uh maybe I
produce some props scare the line away
right but if I have to fight it
um
if I have to fight it straight on I mean
the thing is that you can even if you
take the back like you can't like bite
it or choke it the main is too big to
lock your hands around you know are you
sure about that because I mean it's just
hair yeah it's thin hair it's like it's
like matted hair right I don't know so I
think you think you can make it back a
drawing a line maintain yeah yeah but
but getting there getting there I think
I fake high go low all right make them
think I'm going for the foot or
something a little paw sweep and I take
the back uh what about a what about a
bear I feel like they're easier that
might be easier to take um to hold back
control yeah maybe the thing is if the
bear falls on its back you're just gonna
crush it so it's so big it's
substantially bigger than a line right
like a uh yeah full going and they're
also like terrifyingly like loud with
the rewards and stuff yeah I think I
think so first of all I saw Grizzly I'm
like he's gonna attack me I try to yell
a little bit louder than maybe the term
a little bit like give them yeah uh and
then uh yeah for sure I try to get
behind it I probably go like uh
something weird maybe like pull the eyes
out or something you know for sure I
mean I'm going for the vital organs you
know I'm play dead play dead and then
oil check it there's no there's no pride
in that
well Pride even matters see the ego the
same advice you gave you got to put the
ego aside with a bear
even then
even then uh uh would you how would you
fight a bear or a lion just play dead
like that yeah could you be the kangaroo
a kangaroo uh yeah kangaroo I'd beat the
[__] out kangaroo yeah yeah I mean are
we boxing ghosts we just like how would
a kangaroo attack a human try to kick
him with the claws knock them down and
then they chug him stand on that tail
the kangaroos do yeah they don't choke
each other you don't believe me you
wanna watch your video they check each
other out
[Laughter]
strange [__] like if there's a predator
around that weight in a pool of water
and then if it comes to attack they're
pretty smart